To what extent do you think your tips
for young people clean your room mate
deschedule read great books are
predicated on your own personality?
Well,
I think they're predicated on my
personality to some degree.
I think that a lot of my
conscientiousness such as it is,
has been learned.
I think our disciplined myself,
particularly in graduate school,
so I don't think it was necessarily an
intrinsic part of my personality.
I think it's something that I learned to
do because I felt that I had something
that was worthwhile to do.
So,
um,
it's very difficult to answer it beyond
that because,
you know,
I am affected by my own personality
obviously.
Although I think that I give advice
that's pretty balanced across all the
dimensions,
you know,
like I think that you should be capable
of speaking in public fluently and that
you should be able to communicate with
groups of people.
I think that you should be able to be
solitary work on your own.
So that covers it.